le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
avec l'emploi le logement est l'un des
grands enjeux sociaux de l'île le
département propose aux réunionnais
plusieurs dispositifs liés à l'habitat
il s'adresse particulièrement aux
personnes âgées ou handicapées et aux
familles aux revenus modestes
rollon est le père d'une petite fille de
11 ans atteinte de mucoviscidose
hélène était locataire depuis plus de
trente ans d'un logement dit très social
tous deux ont bénéficié de l'aide du
département
[Musique]
comme chaque matin rôle on accompagne sa
fille à l'école
cassandra à 11 ans elle est scolarisée
au collège de l'antre 2
aux blue bombers
pourtant aujourd'hui la petite famille
vient de saint pierre où elle réside
temporairement depuis quelques semaines
leur maison est inhabitable
voilà vous êtes en plein chantier on est
en train de remettre un peu d'ordre
là-dedans et le plus important c'est la
voile à l'aménagement qui est effectué
pour ma fille cassandra souffre de
mucoviscidose une maladie génétique
lourde qui nécessite une prise en charge
spécifique et un cadre de vie adapté la
maison n'était pas
adapté à sa pathologie dont conséquences
il faut absolument faire un truc spécial
pour elle au niveau sanitaire comme ça
personne ne touche pas elle utilise
seulement le sien voilà qu'on s'offre
une petite réparation pour éviter les
germes les microbes et tous les toits
sans que sauter d'infection surinfection
ça n'arrangeait pas les choses cure
après qu'eurent l'hôpital afin dossier
général
c'est quand yves
rolland a donc pu bénéficier de l'aide
départementale à l'amélioration de
l'habitat une enveloppe qui finance en
partie des travaux liés à la sécurité
l'accessibilité ou l'hygiène pour les
personnes âgées ou handicapées
mais ce dispositif s'adresse aussi aux
familles modestes qui souhaiteraient
devenir propriétaire
à sainte marie hélène vit dans ce
logement depuis plus de 30 ans si
jusqu'ici elle n'était que locataire
l'endroit est petit à petit devenu son
cocon ou voit très bien que madame est
maintenant très garage et que ma nana
même mon parc d'animaux man en amont
bonne volaille mme ocana voilà
j'ai toujours habité dame déçu maison
par terrain voilà donc je voulais une
maison par terre j'aime pas du tout
c'est pour pouvoir faire des rénovations
dans cette maison qu'elle aime tant qu
elle n a sauté le pas et est devenu
propriétaire pour financer son projet
elle a fait appel au département qui a
dans un premier temps pris en charge ces
frais de notaire la maison a commencé à
affluer un tout petit peu la toile était
complètement abîmé 1 j'ai fait une
demande d'amélioration d'habitat en six
mois j'ai eu la réponse est je suis très
satisfait atteint j'ai eu trois mille
euros pour le noter que j'ai dû rajouter
quelques sous dessus une fois maîtresse
des lieux hélène a pu bénéficier de
subventions supplémentaires pour les
travaux les plus urgents depuis je suis
propriétaire j'ai changé toute la
toiture
je fais
toutes les poses de l'estrie cité parce
que c'était pas bon c'était puis dans
les normes celle de paramore j'ai tout
refait donc j'ai eu
onze mille quelques euros pour
l'ensemble de ses travaux pour pouvoir
intervenir sur son logement hélène a
donc bénéficié de l'aide à la
régularisation du statut d'occupation
qui permettent aux personnes en logement
très social ou en situation d'indivision
d'accéder à la propriété la politique en
faveur du logement est une politique
départementale profondément humaine
puisque c'est une politique qui met le
réunionnais au coeur de ceux de son
projet de vie à voir sa maison
l'améliorer quand on n'a pas les bonnes
conditions que ce soit pour une pièce
l'électricité pour le handicap eh bien
ce sont des conditions qui permettent la
dignité humaine au fond quand tu y es un
citoyen vient vous voir il a besoin de
deux choses ils vous disent un travail
je un logement parce que ce sont des
conditions de son propre projet de vie
on peut ne pas avoir d'emploi mais avoir
un toit rentrer chez soi et s'y sentir
bien c'est ainsi que l'une des
conditions du bonheur tout simplement
alors on rend souvent le sourire aux
familles réunionnaises à chaque fois
qu'on intervient sur des dispositifs
d'amélioration de l'habitat
[Musique]
le département propose au public les
plus défavorisés plusieurs types d'
aides liées à l'habitat l'aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat est une
subvention de 7000 à 14000 euros elle
permet de prendre en charge des travaux
liés à la sécurité l'accessibilité ou
l'hygiène
le département veut aussi aider les
publics vulnérables à accéder à la
propriété il propose une subvention
maximale de six mille euros aux
locataires du parc locatif social l'aide
à la régularisation du statut
d'occupation prend en charge les frais
de notaire à hauteur de 3000 euros
maximum elle s'adresse aux personnes en
logement très social ou dans une
situation d'un division pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez vous adresser
à la direction de l'habitat au 02 62 23
56 00 ou consulter le site du
département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]